Flimsy white sheets shaped
like the seat, paper toilet liners can be
found in many public bathrooms.
Notably, however, while they may provide reassurance
to the germaphobic and finicky, toilet seat
covers have little else to offer in terms
of decreasing your odds of being infected
with some pathogen when sitting on the toilet
seat.
Once thought to be capable of conducting sexually
transmitted diseases (STDs), contrary to popular
belief, today scientists know that toilet
seats are very poor vehicles for spreading
such maladies (like herpes and HIV).
This is due to the relative fragility of these
viruses outside of a human host, as well as
the very effective protective barrier offered
by the skin of your backside.
(Note, however, that if you have an open cut
or other wound on your derriere, it is possible
one of these viruses could get through in
that scenario.)
Of course, this doesn’t mean that viruses
and bacteria aren’t sometimes present on
toilet seats, and, in fact, an eight-year
old girl once caught gonorrhea (Neisseria
gonorrhoeae) from one; however, she didn’t
get it by sitting on the seat, she picked
it up when she tried to use toilet paper to
clean the soiled seat off and got the microbes
on her hand.
In addition to a few, short-lived STDs, toilet
seats may have germs like E. coli and streptococcus;
however, neither of these can typically invade
a body through the skin, so the only way they
will make you sick is if they get on your
hands and you don’t then wash your hands
before eating or the like.
Nonetheless, some people have very sensitive
skin and seats covered with certain allergy
triggers like chemical cleaners, paints, or
varnishes may cause contact dermatitis, a
condition seat covers would help prevent.
In addition, the truly fastidious would find
themselves in a difficult position if toilet
seat liners weren’t available.
For the biggest germaphobes, toilet paper
strategically placed on top of the toilet
seat liner may also ease your mind, albeit
not actually accomplishing much in terms of
disease prevention over what your skin already
offers.
Of course, when a toilet containing fecal
matter is flushed, it tends to result in microbes
and bits of said matter being sprayed about,
including landing on that latch handle you
touched, exposed bits of toilet paper and,
yes, the exposed part of the disposable toilet
seat liners…
It could be worse, though.
In Ancient Rome, a wet sponge on a stick was
often used for wiping.
That may sound very comfortable and appealing
until you learn that, after being used, the
sponge was placed back in a tub of salt water
to await the next person to come along and
wipe with it.
Even if the salt content was sufficiently
strong to kill off any microbes.
Ewww.